i have to tell you i was giggling out
loud several times in the theater while
watching this movie it was so funny uh
sandra you said that your kids were so
excited that you got to work with daniel
radcliffe aka mr harry potter himself
dan they call him dan
they call him dan they're loud yeah yeah
he's on he's on a like he's closer to my
kids oh yeah that we're very we have a
whole we're you know yeah that's andre
yeah no she didn't yeah
you're good yeah absolutely
i love that uh dan i was now i'm gonna
call you dan i haven't earned it yet but
you definitely can i go by dan it's all
good
okay it's good uh who in your life is
over the moon when they found out that
you were working with sandra uh my
girlfriend uh my girlfriend was beside
herself with excitement i was like i
hadn't finished reading the script and
she was like but you have to do it right
and i was like it's really good script
i'm probably going to do it don't worry
um but yeah like me me and aaron uh
you know have been fans of sandy ever
like we watched while you were sleeping
every christmas in our house there is uh
yeah that was a it was a great
excitement and then all the other women
in my life were very excited about
channing tatum and brad pitt maybe erin
was as well but for my sake she kept
that to herself
well speaking of brad pitt he had like
one of the funniest cameos in this movie
did you feel a little left over you
didn't share any scenes with him
um got it but but but also uh you know i
didn't want to run down to set and be
like oh mr bird i'm down i'm also in the
film um so i didn't i didn't want to uh
do that
i love that uh you know listen this
movie is getting such great reviews uh
if there was if there was to be a lost
city spin-off sandra do you think you
could see brad pitt and daniel radcliffe
starring in it
i mean i think i could see um oscar
nunez heading it up oscar nunez first
and randy the goat i think they would be
the one the catalyst to sort of get the
the like but where would we take where
where you can't i can't think of any
place better than the dominican republic
like what
yeah and what am i what are we searching
for yeah i don't know i mean maybe we're
breaking him out of prison
i mean i don't know what i've done to
earn that but that's the thing i feel
like you said it the other days like i
can't conceive of a world where a sequel
makes sense but if the if dana fox can
write something she can write something
anyone can do it then she can she can
write anything i love it i would be game
for that um sandra you recently
announced that you're taking a break
from acting to spend i didn't announce
it
someone asked we were in the whole thing
no i know but did i didn't make it all
the way
sorry i'm just i'm laughing all day
because she's been getting this question
all day and i'm just like to watch this
passing comment evolve into this is so
nuts we were all asked what's next for
you and everyone had some great you know
great project and i said actually i'm
just gonna take some time to be
under my roof and you know
not be in front of the camera and be
with the kids and everyone was like
why why why would you do like so i i am
it's a promise i made and it's a it's
something that i feel i i where i want
to be where i want to be
and um i love that you know and that's
that's um i didn't realize it would be
news but i think it was just
i mean i've taken a break before and
disappeared and nobody cared so
i just i just want to be with the people
that i love
24 7. well i love that the question that
i was going to ask was who is an actor
who you haven't worked with yet who's on
your bucket list that would bring you
back into acting for a little bit of
time no
i mean be
comedy anybody comedic anybody that
could
just raise you to their level
there's so many great comedians um
[Music]
god i don't know i don't know i would
have to go back in time really
you know there's so many great comics
and actors who just
did it all and just in their presence
anyone that could improvise anyone that
could just
give you two chairs and a phone book now
make a scene out of it you know um
[Music]
old you know just
the old classics you know that that
could bring about but i i don't know i
mean i i never know what i want to do
next until it arrives in front of me and
i go that's where i want to be like this
film came to me years before i actually
saw it again and then decided it was the
right thing to do i didn't like it the
first time i read it no way so what made
you want to do it again
because it was
they brought they brought it to me and
they said you can produce it do what you
want do a rewrite cast it find the
directors do whatever you want and i
think because they gave me
an unencumbered free reign i could see
it i could see where it needed to go
rather than where it was
and i think i was also ready for it you
know i'd done a lot of serious stuff and
i was like it's time to laugh so
it was just all those things coming
together
well thank you so much guys i had a
blast watching thank you thank you